on vous emmène à présent à la découverte
d'un métier presque disparu celui de
rémouleur ou affûteur philippe delaunay
est le seul à pratiquer encore cette
activité en indre et loire entre ses
mains tout ce qui est tranchant reprend
vie mais ce seront confinement tombe
comme un coup de marteau les restaurants
fermés ou presque
il a de moins en moins de commandes
samuel colin je suis originaire d'un
milieu rural non j'étais passionné des
passionnés de vieux métiers passionnés
des vieux outils comme deux fois par
mois philippe est là dès 6h30 ce magasin
spécialisé voit d'habitude passer
beaucoup de restaurateurs
pour lui c'est un moyen de remplir son
carnet de commandes viennent faire leurs
courses façon très rapide parce qu'il
faut tourner très vite aux fourneaux
pour être prêt 2010 donc ils n'ont pas
le temps d'amener tout leur matériel
dont ils me contactent ils me voient la
rockhal à rendez-vous
et puis je me déplace à cheval entre
deux départements
il fait environ quarante cinq mille
kilomètres par an dans son camion en
indre et loire
c'est le dernier affûteur présent lors
du premier confinement il fait contre
mauvaise fortune bon coeur
et alors que la france manque de masques
il se met à la disposition des
couturières
je me suis dit battant cas rien faire ne
pouvoir rien faire j'ai dit il faut je
veux aller aider ces couturières qu'on
te sortir des ciseaux des terroirs chez
nous dit solidaire avec elle et je me
suis déplacé dans tous les villages
d'indre et loire entre le rebond
d'activité et là tout l'été en plus des
couteaux ils affûtent outils de jardin
de menuiserie ou encore de coiffure mais
c'est de nouveau le calme plat
l'enseigne change même ses horaires et
ferme en milieu d'après midi
ce second confinement est un coup dur à
nouveau presque plus inquiétant
économiquement que le premier pour lui
je me trouve privé clientèle je me
trouve privé de deux présents sur les
marchés puisque je fais partie des des
professions non nécessaire je me trouve
privé de la clientèle de restaurateurs
puisqu'ils sont fermés j'ai les clés
coiffeur qui sont fermés et coiffeuses
qui sont fermées parce qu'eux aussi ont
leur a demandé de faire baisser de
rideau
aujourd'hui il ne lui reste quasiment
plus que les bouchers charcutiers
traiteurs comme clientèle active